hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 finnish thriller and body horror
movie called hatching which follows the
story of a seemingly ordinary family
whose daughter finds a mysterious egg
that grows into a strange creature
resembling her
the movie begins with a seemingly
ordinary scandinavian family young girl
tina her brother matias and her parents
tinia is an aspiring gymnast while
sophia her mother is an influencer who
regularly records her family's
activities to be uploaded as vlog
content visualizing a perfect happy
family
suddenly a crow breaks into the house
and destroys the furniture after tina
catches it sofia breaks the crow's neck
effectively killing it then tells tina
to dump it in the garbage bin outside
after disposing of the crow she meets
her new neighbor rita who is playing
with her dog rosa when tina wants to pet
it rosa attempts to bite her confusing
rita because it is unlikely for a dog to
do so
at night tina helps sophia sing a
lullaby to matias
after he is asleep they edit the vlog
unable to fall asleep she stares at the
window feeling that something is not
quite right
she checks the garbage bin to find the
crow she dumped earlier has disappeared
but can hear its sounds in the distance
she finds it in the nearby woods and
hits its head with a stone repeatedly
until it surely dies
surprisingly she finds an egg the crow
attempted to hatch in its final breaths
she brings the egg home and incubates it
under her huge teddy bear doll the next
day tina is practicing gymnastics at
school
she needs to get ready for the upcoming
gymnastic competition
she hesitates to do the last flip
disappointing herself but strives to do
better next time
arriving home she finds sophia having an
affair with another man whom sophia
introduces as taro
after tara leaves sophia explains to her
daughter that tara was her special
friend and makes her promise to keep the
affair a secret
life seems to go on normally for the
family
sophia watches tina improve in her
gymnast practices with the hope she can
be sent for the competition
turns out their neighbor rita also goes
to the same school and is interested in
joining the gymnastics competition
she demonstrates her skills in front of
the coach which turns out to be better
than tina enraged sophia pushes tina to
practice a perfect landing until tina's
hands hurt before she falls asleep every
night tina regularly checks the egg for
signs of life and promises to take care
of it
the egg appears to grow to an
inexplicably big size compared to normal
eggs one evening sophia confesses to
tina that she loves tarot which leaves
her devastated she cries while hugging
the giant egg not knowing what to do
except continue being the obedient
daughter her mom always cherishes
the egg absorbs her tears and then
cracks open
she hides in the closet and is freaked
out to see a big creature coming out of
the egg
it peeks into the closet but jumps out
of the window when tina's father calls
out
tina lies to him telling him it was a
bird that struck her window
the next day the creature returns then
tina begins taking care of it and they
seem to bond naming it ally
matias wants to use the bathroom but
tina forbids him because she is still
bathing ally
after bathing it she sings a lullaby for
it to sleep underneath her bed
later she has trouble sleeping due to
rose's annoying barking while the
creature leaves the house
when she finally falls asleep she seems
to have a nightmare which is actually
ali's vision
she is then woken up by ally who comes
back and presents her with a decapitated
rosa
surprised she vomits on the floor
the creature eats her vomit just like a
baby bird eats from its parents
regurgitated food
she buries the dog corpse and while
doing that matias secretly watches her
matias reports to his father that tina
would not let him use the bathroom last
night and she also went out of the house
they entered tina's room surprised to
find her lying on the floor to conceal
ally
seeing blood stains on the bed sheet
their father deduces tina as having her
period
tina's preoccupied mind with ali makes
her forget gymnastic practice
she walks home with rita who tells her
about her missing dog
returning home matias still angry with
his sister retrieves rose's corpse from
the backyard and presents it to their
parents then he pushes tina
she falls to the floor seemingly
connecting herself to ally
angry sofia sends montias to his room
but he notices a passing shadow in
tina's room and goes to check on it he
meets ali underneath tina's bed but it
quickly hides in the closet when sophia
comes
sophia only discovers tina's torn
gymnastic suit and is disappointed that
her daughter does not take the gymnastic
competition seriously while in reality
it is ally who broke the suit
later that night ali approaches sofia in
her sleep leaving traces of its mucus on
her
sophia wakes up sensing something is not
right
matias comes to her telling her that
tina is a monster
she consoles him assuring it is just a
nightmare
tina continues taking care of ali who
begins to grow hair resembling hers
during the gymnastic practice which
sofia observes she feels more pressure
from her mother to out-perform rita
after the practice ali follows rita home
scaring her with its human-like
appearance and hurting her at the same
time tina screams as she can feel what
ali feels sophia assumes her daughter is
panicking before the competition and
suggests they spend the weekend at
tarot's place to calm herself
in her room she finds out that ali's jaw
has detached which means it looks more
like a human rather than a bird now on
the weekend tina and sophia go to taro's
house they meet his baby helmi whose
mother died while giving birth she meets
ally now fully resembling her except for
her pale eyeballs and deformed lower jaw
when they are having breakfast sophia
receives a call informing her that rita
is hospitalized due to being attacked
some time ago
however when tina pays her a visit rita
screams and scares her reliving the
night when ali attacked her then tina
tries practicing gymnastics in the
backyard with tarot who consoles her
that it is okay to not live up to
sophia's pressure
when she hears a disturbing sound she
goes to check on ally and feeds her
tarot knocks on her door but she blocks
it however with his strength tarot
succeeds in pushing the door open
revealing ali while the real tina hides
behind the door
ali scrambles towards him hurting one of
his hands
he forgives tina though and claims to
sophia that he got hurt by one of his
equipment
the day of the gymnastic competition
arrives tina reluctantly leaves with
sophia while taro stays in the house
with helmy although tina begs that helmy
needs to come with her
she knows ally will attack helmi soon
because of her resentment towards helmi
when she is performing ally approaches
sleeping helmy to hurt her with an axe
in its hand
seeing that ally is about to hurt helmi
tinia deliberately injures herself
during the performance to stop ali's
doing
tarot coming to check on his daughter
assumes tina is trying to hurt helmy
because he sees ali's face clearly
meanwhile tina receives medical
attention and is immediately brought
home by sophia sophia could not contain
her embarrassment that her daughter lost
the competition she has live streamed on
her social media tarot is angry when
sophia and tina come to his house
believing that tina attacked helmi
sophia tries to console him but to no
avail and tara banishes both of them
from his house
frustrated sofia hits her own head on
the steering wheel until she bleeds
screaming to tina that she would not let
her be happy
arriving home tina blames ally for
ruining its life and banishes it from
her room tina's father sees ali out in
the yard thinking it is tina
meanwhile sophia tries to record a vlog
but clearly could not hide her
disappointment
tina tries to talk to her but sophia
tells her that she smells
while tina is bathing sophia goes to
tina's room to find ellie crawling
inside the closet mistaking it for tina
she comments on how ruined her
daughter's appearance is and begins
brushing her tangled hair
she brushes too hard ripping a chunk of
its hair
realizing ally is not her daughter sofia
freezes as ally approaches and attacks
her
teenia coming from the bathroom is
shocked to see the scene and quickly
separates ally from her mother
she explains to sophia that ali is the
one who has been ruining her life then
ali runs away they plan to eliminate it
and arm themselves with knives then
begin looking throughout the house for
ally
turns out ali attacks sofia again
knocking her knife onto the floor
finally sofia regains the knife and
stabs ali's thigh however the same wound
and pain is also felt by tina
sophia is determined to kill ali but
tina still hesitates because she knows
hurting ally means hurting her too
however sofia quickly moves to stab
ali's heart to her surprise tina steps
in front of her causing tina to be
stabbed instead of ally realizing what
she has done sophia cries while tina
slowly falls to the floor
tina's tears reach ally's face causing
its jaw to repair and its eyes to darken
now ally is an exact copy of tina's
appearance as sophia stares at it in
horror it attempts to call her mother
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching